oui oui oui vous avez bien lu le titre
les kaka sont de vrais trésors pour les
archéologues parce que ce sont des fous
une merde au sens littéral je veux dire
parce que certains d'entre eux sont
spécialisés dans les excréments et pas
parce qu'on fait un métier de merde on
cherche des crottes mais des crottes
fossilisés des crottes du passé oui
deuxième information que vous pourrez
replacer pour briller en société ou pas
les cas cap ce fossile quelqu'un
fossilisés on appelle ça un coup
politique de coop rousse excréments il
lie tous la pierre
merci j'en ai sauf que vous allez me
dire mais quand bon c'est possible que
ça se fossilise à kaka vu que ça se
dégrade normalement non non absolument
rien demandé en effet c'est compliqué
d'avoir un beau coprolithe et pour y
arriver le comportement du couleurs de
bronze est très important par exemple
celle enfouissons ferrero saen puisque
ça évite l'oxydation ou sa consommation
par des animaux mangeurs de kaka quoi
ensuite il faut qu'il y ait une
minéralisation de la crotte et pour cela
c'est mieux c'est l'artiste est
carnivore notamment parce que son
alimentation contiendra plus de calcium
ce qui facilite ce procès on peut aussi
retrouver des kaka très vieux pas
fossilisées métaux sec parce qu'ils ont
été faits dans des déserts et c'est
génial parce qu'ils contiennent encore
de l'adn ceux là où les appelle pas des
coprolithe n'était pas les hauts faits
c'est ce oui moi aussi je trouve ça
merveilleux la langue française hormis
arrête donc vous comprenez bien que
c'est très rare et très précieux de
trouver des cacas du passé c'est pour ça
que c'est littéralement des trésors pour
les archéologues bon ok mais qu'est-ce
que ça peut bien avoir d'intéressant un
étron cailloux et 20 plein de choses
déjà on peut savoir quel animal à
démouler sombre unis là et donc quelle
espèce humaine ou pas se trouver sur
place
on peut aussi savoir qu'est ce que cette
espèce manger et donc qu'est ce qui
l'entouré en termes de faune et de flore
et bien sûr on peut déduire énormément
d'informations personnelles sur le
poseur de pêche lui même alors lui il
était borgne gémeaux à son embellie mais
non tu arrives à savoir tout ça dans son
caca
non je déconne par contre il a le désert
et la tuberculose as tu fais chier c'est
le cas de le dire parce que le temps
pour la merde
et oui avec le coprolite on peut savoir
si son designer était en bonne santé ou
pas s'il avait des maladies des carences
des parasites des bactéries etc
ouais il ya des gens qui lisent l'avenir
dans les lignes de la main et dot le
passé dans les lignes de la merde je
peux vous dire que vous êtes dans la
merde elle il y a deux disciplines pour
analyser les boudins fossilisés la
paléogénomique qui étudie le génome des
espèces disparues et la paléopathologie
qui étudie par exemple malformations et
leurs maladies infectieuses bref une
véritable enquête et des métiers
passionnants j'ai envie de dire qu'ils
doivent pas s'emmerder
lol bien évidemment beaucoup plus de
choses à dire sur l'archéologie du caca
alors pour en savoir plus je vous
suggère la lecture
super livre retour vers le palais au de
clotilde shanxi jennifer et pierre
kerner et marion sabourdy et qui est ma
source pour cette vidéo et puis bien sûr
pour tout savoir sur le caca il ya le
livre de julien ménielle tout ce que
vous devez savoir sur le plus tabou des
sujets et si vous avez trouvé que cet
épisode c'était pas de la mer vous
pouvez le dire en commentaire même un
pouce pour soutenir sur tipis et surtout
partager à tous vos amis qui font caca
je suis sûr que vous en connaissez pas
les desseins des petits et trop mignon
ont été assurés par notre lemine lui
préféré aller voir son instinct il est
extrêmement bien
réponse est là comme toutes les blagues
de cette vidéo voilà bisous
[Musique]
enregistrement mannequin et au logeo du
cha cas
[Musique]